-Il est têtu comme un Breton
et ça tombe bien.
Mon invité a passé
l'essentiel de sa vie
à défendre la langue
et la culture bretonnes,
y compris au palais Bourbon.
Générique
...
Bonjour Paul Molac.
-Bonjour.
-Le 8 avril 2021
avec quelques collègues députés,
vous vous êtes rendus
sur les marches
du palais Bourbon,
et vous avez entonné
ces quelques notes.
Hymne breton
...
C'est l'hymne breton,
"Bro Gozh Ma Zadoù".
C'était pour célébrer
l'adoption de votre loi
sur l'enseignement
des langues régionales à l'école.
C'est une loi qui fait qu'un élève
en Bretagne peut apprendre les maths
ou la géographie en breton.
Ca s'appelle
l'enseignement immersif.
Ce que vous célébrez ce jour-là
devant le palais Bourbon,
c'est une victoire
contre quoi ?
-C'est une victoire
de la démocratie,
des territoires
sur la technocratie.
-Et une certaine conception
de la République ?
Celle portée par Jean-Michel
Blanquer par exemple ?
-Sur une norme définie par l'Etat
qui devrait s'imposer
à tous, y compris dans
ce que vous devez parler et être.
Donc on sort
de la politique pour s'attacher
à façonner le citoyen,
y compris
sa culture, selon une norme
qui viendrait de Paris.
Ce qui a été fait bien souvent.
Et nous, on dit non.
On a une langue.
-Je parlais de la conception
de Jean-Michel Blanquer.
Vous vous êtes opposé à lui,
quand il était ministre
de l'Education nationale.
Il a appelé à rejeter votre loi.
Il a pas été entendu.
-Non, effectivement.
Les 2/3 du groupe LREM de l'époque
a voté la loi.
Mais c'est une conception de l'Etat,
et comme il le dit lui-même,
en France,
c'est l'Etat qui fait le citoyen.
Je pense qu'en démocratie,
c'est le citoyen qui fait l'Etat.
-On en parlera plus tard.
Pour en revenir à cet hymne breton
sur les marches du palais Bourbon,
on sent chez vous
un côté provocateur.
Vous aimez défier l'autorité,
le pouvoir central ?
-J'ai toujours été comme ça,
mes enseignants s'en plaignaient.
Là, c'est un hasard.
Les collègues voulaient chanter
quelque chose en breton.
Bon alors,
y a bien des chansons à boire,
mais c'était pas le lieu.
Et j'ai pensé : "Le seul air
qu'ils doivent connaître
"avec quelques paroles,
"ça doit être le "Bro Gozh"."
-C'est un symbole fort,
un hymne régional.
-Oui.
-National pour vous.
-Alors, oui,
mais si on prend les Gallois
par exemple,
ça ne pose pas de problème.
On a le même air
avec les mêmes paroles.
Eux en gallois, nous en breton.
Ca pose pas de problème
quand ils le chantent là-bas.
C'est pas tourné contre quelqu'un.
On dit ce qu'on est.
Mais faut pas le voir
comme un nationalisme belliqueux,
revengeur, ou quoi que ce soit.
-Vous vous êtes engagé
à 17 ans,
pour défendre la culture,
l'identité bretonne.
Vous avez recueilli
des traditions orales du pays gallo
d'où vous êtes originaire.
Et vous vous êtes inscrit aux cours
du soir pour apprendre la langue
bretonne.
Pourquoi ce besoin de vous tourner
vers cette identité bretonne ?
-Dans mon parcours scolaire,
je m'étais interrogé sur le fait
que nous étions en Bretagne
et qu'on ne m'en parlait jamais
à l'école.
Ca me paraissait bizarre.
J'ai commencé par chercher moi-même.
Donc j'ai demandé
à Noël, quand j'étais en 5e,
un bouquin d'histoire de Bretagne.
Y avait pas énormément
de bibliothèques à l'époque.
Et donc, mes parents
ont pris dans la librairie du coin.
Et j'ai lu l'histoire de Bretagne
que j'ignorais.
Je crois qu'une partie de mon combat
est partie de là aussi.
-Sur la langue bretonne,
c'est une langue parlée encore
aujourd'hui dans le Finistère.
Vous êtes du Morbihan.
Dans votre département,
on parle plus
le breton depuis 5 siècles.
Pourquoi vouloir vous raccrocher
à une langue qui est plus vraiment
ancrée dans votre territoire ?
-Sur Ploërmel, oui,
mais le reste du Morbihan, non.
Je suis pas loin
de la zone historique
qu'on appelle Basse-Bretagne.
Et comme je le dis,
je m'appelle Molac,
c'est un nom breton.
Je suis né à Ploërmel, et je vis
à Taupont, ce sont des noms bretons.
-Y a un village Molac
pas loin de chez vous.
Ce gilet que vous portez là,
c'est un gilet breton,
on l'appelle le glazik,
vous le portez dans l'hémicycle
depuis votre réélection en 2022.
Vous le portez sur la photo
officielle prise de vous
à l'Assemblée.
C'est un geste politique
et en même temps,
ce gilet fait pas partie
de vos traditions locales.
Il vient du Finistère, de Quimper.
-Oui, alors...
-Ma question, c'est :
est-ce que c'est pas artificiel,
avec un côté folklore dans tout ça ?
-Les traditions, vous savez,
ça se modifie.
On croit que c'est figé, mais non.
A l'Assemblée nationale,
je voulais pas quelque chose
qui soit noir.
Parce que déjà, c'est gris
et bleu souvent profond...
Je voulais trouver quelque chose
avec un peu de couleurs.
Chez nous, y en avait pas vraiment
ou en broderie.
Je suis allé puiser
dans la tradition cornouaillaise
où c'est un bleu.
Quelques fois,
ça peut être rouge d'ailleurs.
Quand j'ai vu mon collègue Moetai...
-Moetai Brotherson,
de Polynésie.
-Avec sa chemise à fleurs,
avec son espèce de kilt,
je me suis dit
qu'il fallait changer un peu.
On est tous un peu corbeau.
-Vous avez trouvé
un débouché politique
à ce combat en 2012,
vous avez été investi
aux législatives,
dans le Morbihan,
avec le soutien du PS,
d'Europe Ecologie,
et de l'Union Démocratique Bretonne.
On est un peu venu vous chercher
mais finalement,
la politique est la suite logique
du combat
que vous menez.
-Oui, mais je cherchais pas
à être élu.
J'avais plutôt cherché
à travailler
dans les associations.
Et j'étais devenu comme ça président
de l'association
pour l'enseignement du breton
à l'école publique,
au niveau Bretagne.
Je travaillais comme ça
car je me voyais pas...
Je suis peut-être trop indépendant
pour être dans un parti.
-Une fois élu,
vous avez poursuivi votre combat.
Ca a donné lieu parfois
à des prises de parole étonnantes.
-Le fait que la République
lie la langue française
avec la citoyenneté
m'a toujours paru curieux.
Il n'empêche que quand le français
est la langue commune,
et on le comprend bien.
Mais je dirais que...
Il parle breton.
Donc la langue de mon coeur
et de mon âme est bien le breton.
Ca ne fait pas de moi un Français
pire que les autres.
Pas forcément meilleur non plus,
d'ailleurs.
Mais la langue ne fait pas
le citoyen.
-La langue ne fait pas le citoyen.
Et vous allez même un peu plus loin,
dans une interview,
en vous définissant
comme un citoyen français
de nationalité bretonne.
Ca veut dire
que vous ne vous reconnaissez pas
dans la nation française ?
-Je pense que la nation française
est plurielle.
La nation française
n'est pas le clone
ou la norme
que l'Etat a voulu nous imposer.
-Vous vous identifiez
à cette pluralité
de la nation française ?
-Oui, bien sûr.
Il faut faire une différence
entre ce qui est
nos droits politiques
que nous exerçons ensemble,
et pour l'intérêt général,
je l'espère.
Ca, c'est le politique.
Je dis bien
que je suis citoyen français.
Je m'inscris
dans cette chose politique.
Après, la nation,
c'est ce qui m'est propre.
Et donc quand...
Et de dire, il n'y a
qu'une seule nation en France...
Je prendrais les paroles
de Pierre Joxe,
le statut sur la Corse :
Peuple corse, partie intégrante
du peuple français.
-Une nation, c'est partager
un destin, un projet commun.
Vous ressentez ça
vis-à-vis du territoire français ?
-Oui, nous partageons des choses
en tant que Français,
mais nous partageons aussi
des choses en tant que Bretons.
-Si je veux devenir breton,
dans votre conception
de la nationalité,
que faut-il faire ?
-Vous habitez en Bretagne ?
-Si j'y vis, je peux ?
-Vous êtes breton, c'est tout.
Pour moi, c'est très simple.
On est sur un territoire.
Ce territoire suinte
d'une histoire, d'une culture.
Vous venez là,
vous faites avec les autres,
vous en faites partie, point.
-A l'Assemblée, vous avez été membre
des groupes écologiste,
socialiste, LREM, et enfin Liberté
et Territoires, LIOT aujourd'hui.
Vous n'avez jamais adhéré
à un parti, vous l'avez évoqué.
Pourquoi ?
-Je me sens pas à l'aise
dans les partis.
J'aime pas les embrigadements.
On vous dit
qu'il faut faire comme ça.
On trouve toujours des petits chefs
qui vous disent
ce que vous avez à faire.
Et ça, je suis un peu trop
indépendant pour ça.
-C'est pour ça que vous avez quitté
d'abord le groupe écologiste,
puis socialiste,
et en 2017,
vous avez rapidement quitté LREM.
-Le groupe écologiste,
je l'ai pas quitté, il a implosé.
Je me suis retrouvé
sans groupe.
Il a fallu
que je trouve quelque chose.
-En 2017, vous êtes dans LREM
et vous avez été vite mal à l'aise.
-Oui.
-"J'ai découvert
des parlementaires qui attendaient
"les ordres du gouvernement.
"Et ne servaient pas
de contre-pouvoir." Ca vous a agacé.
-Oui, car un député n'est pas là
pour soutenir le gouvernement.
Il est là parce qu'il y a
une séparation des pouvoirs.
On revient aux philosophes.
-Mais si la majorité
soutient pas le gouvernement...
-Vous pouvez soutenir
le gouvernement
tout en lui expliquant que certaines
choses ne sont pas possibles.
Or là...
-Vous aviez pas
votre mot à dire ?
-C'était le cas !
-Aujourd'hui,
vous êtes dans le groupe LIOT,
qui rassemblent des élus corses
des ultramarins, et des élus en
rupture avec leur famille politique.
Votre point commun
serait d'être incasable.
Vous rentrez pas dans les cases.
Mais cela fait-il
une ligne politique ?
-Si vous regardez nos votes,
vous verrez que oui.
-Y a
une certaine liberté de vote.
-Oui, mais quand on regarde bien.
On se retrouve sur ces questions
dont on parle.
Ce qui nous caractérise,
c'est un grand pragmatisme.
Donc les grandes idées, c'est bien.
Mais si elles ne s'incarnent pas
avec des choses réelles,
c'est du blabla.
Donc ça, on est là-dessus.
On a tous une sensibilité
par rapport à nos territoires
d'origine.
-Ca, c'est...
C'est intrinsèque au groupe LIOT.
-Tout à fait.
-C'est l'heure de notre quiz,
à présent.
Je vais commencer des phrases,
ça va être à vous de les terminer.
C'est bon, on y va ?
Quand un député breton
rencontre un député corse...
-Ils se parlent.
-En quelle langue ?
-En français et ils se comprennent.
-D'accord.
J'aurai gagné mon combat
pour la culture bretonne,
le jour où...
-Le jour où on proposera
l'enseignement du breton
dans les écoles en Bretagne.
-Ce qui n'est pas le cas.
-Ce n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui.
-Entre chanter sur scène
ou prendre
la parole dans l'hémicycle...
Si vous deviez choisir ?
-C'est plus plaisant sur scène.
Dans l'hémicycle,
on défend des choses qui sont
de l'organisation globale.
-Mais ce que vous aimez le plus ?
Vous êtes chanteur,
dans un groupe.
-Ferzaè.
Oui, les deux me tiennent à coeur.
C'est complémentaire.
-On va écouter
quelques notes justement,
que vous reconnaîtrez sans doute.
Folklore breton
Vous retrouvez ?
C'est vous qui chantez.
"La Ridée de..."
-"Ridée de Josselin."
-Et ça, ça fera partie de votre vie
après l'Assemblée nationale ?
-Je pense jusqu'au moment
où je pourrai plus monter sur scène.
-On termine en musique.
Merci beaucoup Paul Molac
d'être venu.
-Merci de m'avoir invité.
...
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA